name is Danilo Patrat
and today on behalf of the Yale Center
for the Study of representative
institutions I have the pleasure of
introducing our guest speaker professor
Gordon wood as many of you know our
Center was started last year by
professor of history Keith Wrightson and
professor of political science Stephen
Smith with the support of the Jack
Miller Center our purpose is the closer
study of the theory and practice of
representative government into
anglo-american tradition to find out
more about us please visit our website
Gordon s wood is one of America's
pre-eminent scholars of the founding
period here at Yale as Professor Smith
reminded me he is better known as the
father of art historian Chris Wood
Gordon wood is the Alva away University
professor and professor of history
emeritus at Brown University he received
his BA degree from Tufts University and
his PhD from Harvard he taught at
Harvard and the University of Michigan
before joining the faculty at Brown in
1969 he is the author of numerous books
among them the creation of the American
Republic 1776 to 1787 which won the
Bancroft prize and the John H Dunning
prize in 1970 and he is the author of
the radicalism of the American
Revolution which won the Pulitzer Prize
for history and the Ralph Waldo Emerson
prize in 1993 he was also recently
awarded the national matter of medal for
the Humanities professor wood reviews in
the New York Review of Books and the New
Republic he's a fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences and the
American Philosophical Society professor
Wood is also a member of the Jack Miller
center academic council in all of the
most famous scenes in the film Good Will
Hunting the character played by Matt
Damon a very bright townie kid working
Cambridge Massachusetts gets into an
argument with a harvard graduate student
whom he accuses of uncritically
parroting the views of the authors on
his
reading list the clever townie that goes
on to predict that a little later in the
studies the graduate student would soon
be quote regurgitating Gordon would an
implication is that the best and the
brightest in our institutions of higher
learning are content to follow the
well-established opinions well this
afternoon you're invited to try to prove
Hollywood wrong to go beyond
regurgitation and if you wish to engage
critically with some of Professor Woods
ideas on the subject of representation
in the American Revolution question and
answer session will follow please come
up to one of the mics as we're recording
this talk today thank you again for
coming and please join me in welcoming
professor wood to this podium well thank
you very much for that very generous
introduction
actually what Matt Damon's character
goes on to say what if you really want
to read a good book you got to read
Howard Zinn Howard Zinn was a close
friend of the the late Howard Zinn was a
close friend of the Damon's family yeah
they all grew up in Boston now okay this
is about representation in the American
Revolution and I think of all the
conceptions of political theory that run
through that period from the 1760s to
the drafting of the Constitution
there's none more important than the
issue of representation beginning of
course with the Imperial crisis in the
1760s and extending to the debate over
the Constitution 1787 in each case those
great debates are about representation
in fact if representation is defined as
the means by which people participate in
government the fulfillment of a proper
representation I think became the goal
and the measure of the Revolution itself
the whole object of the present
controversy as Jefferson put it in 1776
there for representation wasn't simply
an issue between the British and the
Americans it was an issue among
the Americans themselves and in the
process Americans began fashioning a
radically new conception of
representation I think new at least in
the english-speaking world and a
conception whose implications were not
fully drawn out until the debate over
the Federal Constitution by 1787 1788
many Americans had come to believe that
they alone among the peoples of the
Western world had come to understand the
true meaning of representation only by
profoundly transforming the traditional
way in which the people participated in
government could Americans explain the
conception of federalism only then could
they explain the revolutionary idea that
the people were equally represented in
two or three or more institutions of
government at the same time and only
then was the modern conception of
democracy indeed I think the modern
conception of politics was made
meaningful now the issue begins I think
serious discussion of it the issue
begins with the Imperial debate in with
Parliament's passage of the Stamp Act
which as you know taxed paper products
essentially in in the colonies
once the English ministry sense the
stirring of colonial opposition to this
Stamp Act a group of English
pamphleteers Abel pamphleteers usually
connected with the government sub
ministers and so on set out to explain
and to justify what they had done in
passing that tax and before they were
finished these British polemicists had
revealed the assumptions on which the
entire British I think English theory of
politics rested although they differed
these various pamphleteers
all of them eventually centered on the
point that the Americans like all
Englishmen were comprehended by a vioxx
of Parliament through a system of what
they called virtual representation even
though the colonists like nine-tenths of
the people of Britain did not in fact
choose any representatives to the House
of Commons declared Thomas Whateley
was the undersecretary who's actually
written the act they were undoubtedly
Whateley went on they were undoubtedly a
part and an important part of the
Commons of Great Britain they are
represented in Parliament in the same
manner as those inhabitants of Britain
who have no voices in elections for the
English election this is hard I think
for us to comprehend but it's important
to comprehended election was incidental
to representation people did not
actually have to vote for members of
parliament to be represented there there
were lots of people in England who did
not vote and yet said Whateley they are
represented in and taxed by Parliament
in fact declared lately all British
subjects were really in the same
situation none are actually all are
virtually represented for every member
of parliament sits in the house not as a
representative as their own constituents
but as one of that august assembly by
which all the Commons of Great Britain
are represented now to most mainstream
Englishmen back home in the mother
country these arguments made a great
deal of sense centuries of history had
left Britain with confusing mixture of
sizes and shapes of its electoral
districts some of the constituencies
were large with thousands of voters but
others were small and more or less in
the pocket of a single landowner many of
the electoral districts had few voters
and some so called rotten boroughs like
Old Sarum had no inhabitants at all but
nonetheless sent two members to the
House of Commons the town of dunnage
continued to send representatives to
Parliament even though it had long since
slipped into the North Sea at the same
time some of England's largest cities
such as Manchester Birmingham Leeds
which had grown subtly in the mid 18th
century these large cities sent no
representatives to the House of Commons
now what made this conception of virtual
representation and virtual we should in
our own world today should come to
appreciate better than the Americans in
the 18th century
what made this conception of virtual
representation intelligible what gave it
force I think in English thought was the
assumption
the English people despite great degrees
of rank and and and property despite
even the separation of three thousand
miles of ocean between the English
subjects they were all essentially a
unitary homogeneous estate or order with
a fundamental common interest that could
be promoted legitimately by an elite
British officials believe that each
member of parliament represented not
just the particular locality he that he
supposedly came from but the whole
British nation as Edmund Burke told his
Bristol constituents in 1774 which is
the most celebrated expression of this
assumption I think in in the literature
in the 18th century Parliament said
Burke was not a congress of ambassadors
from different in hostile interests but
a deliberative assembly of one nation
with one interest that of the whole that
transcended local interests I might
point out that he didn't win that
election in Bristol with that kind of
speech but for this reason the older
medieval requirement that the members of
parliament reside in the constituencies
they represented had long since been
ignored and of course such a residency
requirement isn't even today is not
required for MPS in in Britain it was
also understandable that the English
defenders of virtual representation made
light of the electoral process by which
members were sent to Parliament election
as I say was not what gave the member
his representative power that came
ultimately from the mutuality of
interest that the MP presumably shared
with the whole Commons for whom he spoke
only this concept of virtual
representation said Whateley and this is
a very crucial point I think he put his
finger on a central justification for
virtual representation only this concept
ultimately justified the binding of the
whole people by the consent of the
majority of that of that house when you
think about it if election is the
crucial thing in representation then are
you not represented by the person they
you didn't vote for what if your
opponent wins and this can be handled by
the concept of virtual representation
but it's a little tricky if you don't
believe in that why should you obey a
representative for whom you didn't vote
if election is the criterion as the
Americans thought of representation and
Whateley put his finger on that I think
very important point which justifies
majority rule otherwise there's no real
reason why you should accept the will of
a person that did not get your vote but
of course the Americans immediately
rejected this concept and emphatically
rejected this British claim that they
liked that colonists like the
inhabitants of Manchester and Birmingham
who were virtually represented in the
House of Commons in the same manner as
they put it with the non electors
resident in Great Britain and in the
flood of publications they said that
such a claim was absurd Stamp Act
Congress I think of 1765 summed up the
American position there's a many
different conceptions and they seemed to
shift back and forth but I think they
summed up the American position that the
people of these colonies are not and
from their local circumstances cannot be
represented in the House of Commons in
Great Britain and through all of the
adjustments all the shifting that took
place over the next few years that
fundamental position was never shaken
now in rejecting the British claim that
Americans were virtually represented in
the English House of Commons however
some of the colonists never decisively
repudiated the concept of virtual
representation that is to say they they
knew that they had to be some
justification for why there were non
electors in America who were nonetheless
represented they also believed that
society was a home many of them believed
the society in the colonies was a
organic whole and therefore some elites
could speak for the rest of the society
as a young Alexander Hamilton pointed
out in 1775 the intimate connection of
interest among electors not electives
and representatives and not simply the
right to vote said here
was what really made representation
viable now this is most obvious in the
Americans denial of the franchise two
women and two young men and such such
some such notion of virtual
representation a natural identity of
interest between electors and non
electors lay behind the various property
qualifications for the suffrage that was
generally required even in the new
revolutionary state constitutions
drafted in 1776 when some Americans in
1776 actually objected to these property
qualifications and demanded that the
franchise be extended to all adult males
the Constitution makers were compelled
to fall back on reassertion of in one
form or another of this idea of virtual
representation always emphasizing of
course as Richard Henry Lee did the
great difference between the Americans
case against Britain and that of the run
represented in this country now these
American concessions to the idea of
virtual representation however tended to
be overwhelmed by the outcry that they
could never be virtually represented in
the House of Commons certainly not in
the same way that the non voters of
cities like Manchester and Birmingham
and Sheffield were first some colonists
argued that there was no mutuality of
interest between the colonies in the
mother country so they accepted the
notion of virtual representation but
said well we don't have any mutual
interests and in fact they pointed out
which is a crucial point I think in
terms of thinking about representation
that the the members of parliament and
the English themselves were not sharing
in the tax that was levied on them that
is it was exclusively pointed at the
colonists and they said well how can we
have this if Congress or if the members
of parliament themselves are not being
not have to pay the tax of course they
had their own stamp taxes in England but
nonetheless this was the argument that
many in America made but most I think
simply challenged the whole idea of
virtual representation itself and drew
on the historical experience to replace
it with what they called actual
presentation I mean these terms were
used in the debate if the people were to
be properly represented in a legislature
the columnist said not only did the
people have to vote directly for the
members of the legislature but they also
had to be represented by members whose
numbers were proportionate to the size
of the population they spoke for no no
all serums for them if you're going to
have a district or a new town created
you're going to have to have
representation so what seem meaningful
in England made no sense whatsoever in
the colonies
unlike England electoral districts in
the new world were not the products of
history going back centuries but rather
were recent and regular creations that
were related to changes in population
when new towns in Massachusetts were
created or new counties in Virginia were
formed new representatives customarily
was sent to the respective colonial
legislatures two representatives from
the new town two from two Burgesses to
the House of Burgesses in Virginia now
this system of actual representation
stressed the closest possible connection
between the local electors and the
representatives unlike the English
Americans believe that the
representatives had to be residents of
the localities that they spoke for and
that of course is still true even today
and that people of the localities
generally had the right to instruct
their representatives so they were kind
of ambassadors despite what Burke said
and this I think is more important than
anything was that they thought only fair
that the localities be represented more
or less in proportion to their
population and when the New York draws
up its state constitution 1777 they
write into the Constitution something
that we built into the Federal
Constitution which was an innovation for
the age that every periodically the
representation would be adjusted in
accord with changes in the population in
the state so that what you had I think
by the end of the Constitution making in
the States in 1776 77 the fullest and
most equal
participation of the people in the
processes of government that the world
had ever seen
despite the fact that women could not
vote and that blacks slaves of course
did not vote nonetheless the percentage
of white adult males was higher than
anyplace else in the world as most
places of course didn't have any Sun
Center resembling a representative
system in England probably one out of
six out out males could vote and in
America it was closer to two out of
three now since this actual
representation and this I think is a
crucial point that runs through the
whole pier right up into our own time is
based on the people's mistrust of whom
of those they elected the the colonists
and the Americans pushed for the most
explicit and broadest kind of consent
which of course fundamentally meant at
least initially voting the mutuality of
interests that made virtual
representation meaningful in England was
in America so weak so tenuous that the
representatives could not be trusted to
speak for the interests of their
constituents unless they actually voted
for them there was no sense of really of
mutual trust actual Ripa's
representation thus made the process of
election not incidental as it was in
England but central to the whole process
of representation and this actual
representation I think became the key to
the peculiarities of American
constitutionalism and American
government many Americans wanted elected
officials who were like them like
themselves in every way not only in
ideas in what they promoted as their
platform if you will but in religion in
ethnicity
in social class now you have actually
early examples of this even in 1775 in
pencil in Philadelphia when these
revolutionary committees were formed
committee of 18 committee of 19
committee of 50 the groups kept asking
well why aren't we there and the artisan
said we don't have any artisans on the
committee they're all gentlemen there
are no Germans on the committee we want
some Germans there are no presbyterian
we want some presbyterian to actually
have identity politics emerging as early
as 1775 in America this of course would
continue in of course is very much a
part of American politics today that the
representative not only had to before
the people he had to be of the people
had to resemble the the constituents
that he spoke for now there's a
continual struggle over these issues of
representation during the following
decade into the 1780s which i think is
the most important decade in American
history out of which of course came out
of Constitution and that was not at all
foreseen in 1776 no one in his wildest
imaginations even conceived of such a
strong federal government as emerged so
something awesome something terrific had
to happen in that decade and that's why
and of course it did and that's why I
think the decade is the most important
in our history to make a complicated
story short I believe that the abuses of
the concept of actual representation lay
behind much of the crisis of the 1780s
the critical period was critical because
of democratic excesses fed by these
notions of actual representation
majorities in the state legislatures
were running amok and casting doubt on
the possibility of republican government
and this of course became not just names
Madison's although he's the most
articulate expressor of this view the
this became his central concern how to
curb these rampaging majorities in the
state legislatures how to do that
majoritarian factionalism he called it
anyroad a little essay for his own
working paper called the vices of the
system of the United States which
outlines this fear of excessive demmick
democracy running running wild and the
Federalists designed the Constitution
Madison in particular but he his ideas
are shared by others
at least in large part I think because
of the to solve these abuses to solve
these problems flowing from these
excesses of democracy the Constitution
as a solution to the assesses of
democracy made representation a central
issue in the ratification debates in
fact representation became just as much
of a central issue in 1787 88 as it had
been in 1765 over the Imperial cry
during the Imperial crisis now this is
obeyed as a fascinating one and I think
it's actually interesting and for those
of you interested in political theory I
think it illustrates very sharply how
ideas change under pressure under the
requirements of engaging in popular
debate and you see the ideas changing
bringing before your eyes and I think
it's a fascinating laboratory for the
study of intellectual history the
debates raised once again this old
distinction as I say between actual and
virtual representation I think through
the structural devices of the federal
government
the Federalists sought to promote I
guess you'd have to call it an elitist
although they didn't have that term an
elitist conception of virtual
representation even though political and
social conditions in America were making
such a conception difficult if not
impossible to to sustained
by contrast the opponents of the
Constitution the anti-federalists as
they were called offered a spirited
defense of actual representation indeed
they defended the most localist the most
particular kind of actual representation
voiced in the entire Revolutionary era
and it was a conception of
representation that I think was much
more in accord with the emerging social
and political realities of America or at
least the northern parts of America than
the sort of representation virtual
representation advocated by the
Federalists and that's in that sense the
anti-federalists were on the right side
of history if you will and the
Federalists not at least in
in part it doesn't work out quite so
neatly as that now what did the
Federalists want any of anybody who's
read my some of my work do you know what
I'm what I what I think they saw the
problems of American politics in the
1780 stemming from its against localism
localism in the states in fact from too
much actual representation in these
state legislatures not only had the
great objects of the nation been
sacrificed constantly to local views but
they said the general interests of the
states had been sacrificed to local and
special interests the public good was
lost in the scramble for private
advantages local favors and there's the
whole series of things that Madison
talks about debt a relief legislation
particularly paper money and of course
he illustrates this in large part from
from my own state of Rhode Island which
was considered the pariah state because
it was flooding the whole of southern
New England with paper money and and was
the local estate run wild now such
developments were occurring precisely
because those whom the federal is called
the best people that was a term they
often used people like themselves had
lost control of state politics instead
of choosing men for their abilities
integrity and patriotism said the
Federalists I'm quoting here from
various publications the people in the
various local constituency has had
chosen men because they will vote for
some in favor of some special interest
some special local interests these
representatives constantly constantly
mistook the particular circle in which
they moved for the general voice of the
society they were parochial they were
narrow-minded they had they had elected
to their state legislators men like such
as William Finley of Pennsylvania who's
a former Weaver no education whatsoever
Abraham Yeats of New York who was a
former cobbler men who lacked any kind
of semblance of a college education and
lacked the cosmopolitan outlook of a
college-educated gentleman the spirit of
locality per
voted by such narrow-minded illiberal
and that term was used meaning the
opposite of a liberal arts education
when you don't have that you're a
liberal and that that spirit of locality
concluded James Madison in 1788 was
inseparable he said from the American
practice of electing representatives
some small districts or small towns now
hence the Federalist remedy for the
vices of American politics embodied in
the new national government in the
Virginia Plan that Madison brings to the
convention which provided in his initial
plan for a veto power by the Congress
overall state bills nope no no
legislative no state legislature could
have a bill made into a law until it
passed the Congress not negative that he
wanted was central to a system and when
he didn't get it he was depressed and
disillusioned he thought the system the
whole thing was going to fail but he we
got something else instead we got
article 1 section 10 of the Constitution
which prohibits the states from doing
certain things so what he what they hope
to do with this new national government
was changed the scale and the processes
of representation they were going to put
it to put it bluntly they're going to
narrow the elevate the the electorate
elevate and narrow the decision-making
now this is an insight that you might
say a sociological insight that's been
used time and again in American politics
the progressives were very much Samuel
Hays a historian of 50 years ago 40
years ago wrote wonderfully on this
serious you you you you worried about
would bosses making decisions elevate
the decision-making get somebody else
who's going to make a better decision
when you see a blue ribbon ribbon
Commission's appointed then you realize
that's exactly what's happening you're
just gonna try to get it out of the
minds or out of the hands of the the
local ward bosses and get somebody who's
got a little more a bit a little better
outlook on things to make the decision
that's the kind of insight the
sociological insight that these
Federalists
had the house of representatives in the
new national government when you think
about it this is a four million people
are going to have only sixty five
members the initial house and thus would
be smaller than most of the state
legislatures I mean the Massachusetts
legislature was three hundred and sixty
members suddenly you can have a house
representing the whole country thirteen
states sixty-five think what that meant
and if we compare these 65
representatives with the thousand of wor
state legislative members we get it you
can get a better idea of what the
Federalists were up to take a state like
North Carolina which had 232 people in
its state legislature it's going to have
five congressmen going to the federal
House of Representatives now the idea is
that since there are only about five
college graduates in all of the state of
North Carolina that the chances of the
college graduates ending up in the
federal Congress were very high and they
certainly were not going to be able to
dominate and did not dominate the state
legislature of 232 so you are going to
by elevating decision-making to the
national level you're going to get a
better class of person they would be far
more likely to ignore the illiberal
parochial men the people would in
electing their congressman we ignore
these liberal men with factious tempers
if you read through the federalist
papers there are these cold words that
appear every once in a while madison
especially using them
people with factious tempers local
prejudices who were dominating the state
legislatures they would the people
instead would elect to the new federal
government only those college-educated
few who were in Madison in James
Wilson's words another one of the great
Federalists a man of intelligence and
uprightness these few Gentry it was
hoped would virtually represent all the
diverse interests and occupations of the
whole of this four million people in the
American society so by greatly enlarging
the electoral districts and by severely
seen the number of those who would who
would represent the people and wield
effective political power
the Federalists expected to free America
from the evils of localism that had
become so glaringly evident in the
previous decade the great height of the
of the government the new government
it's great distance from parochial
interests what it was hoped prevent the
obscure illiberal parochial and
narrow-minded men who had gained power
the state governments from scaling its
higher walls the new federal government
said Madison would act as a kind of
sieve filtering and I'm quoting here
from the mass of the society the purest
and noblest characters which it contains
those who would represent the people in
the federal legislature because of the
fewness of numbers and the breadth of
their of the electorate's would be the
best men in the country those natural
social leaders who possess in Madison's
words the most attractive merit and the
most diffusive and established
characters this summary is the
Federalist view of things now they have
the fellas were not stupid they knew
immediately what was happening they knew
that the Federalists were what they were
up to and they counted the Federalists
artificially contrived device for
establishing virtual representation with
a vehement defense of actual
representation and they launched
extraordinary debate in all of the
states some of them more exciting than
others but I should point out that these
debates are being published now up to
about two dozen volumes by now the
editor in chief is John Kaminski at
Madison Wisconsin and it's an
extraordinary collection of documents on
all of the major issues of political
theory on not just on representation but
empower liberty rights a relationship
between rulers and rules all the things
that that political theories that
political theorists are interested in
and and it's extraordinary collection
now there may have been richer debates
in 5th century Athens and there may have
even been richer debates in 17th century
England but we we don't know we don't
have the extent of information about
those debates that we have about the
Americans this is an extraordinary
collection and it's scarcely been
touched because political theory has not
been central to at least two historians
over the last half-century it's only
been in the last forty years that these
things have started being published in
modern editions Kaminsky and his
colleagues have gathered almost
everything together they can think of
that has it for all the newspapers all
the pamphlets that relate to this debate
over the Constitution now the anti
Thunder said over and over again Society
was not a unitary organic hierarchy for
which an elite of gentlemen considered
that it could sympathetically speak it
said instead it was rather a
heterogeneous mixture of many different
classes or orders of people and they set
out a complicated view of American
society made up of every occupation you
could think of merchants farmers plan as
mechanics Gentry or wealthy men each
possessing distinct and often
incompatible interests they claimed that
such a diverse society in such a diverse
society men from one class or group
however educated
however respectable could never be
acquainted with the situation in wants
of those of another class or group in
other words people from one part of the
society could not speak for other
certainly Gentry could not speak for a
artisan or a farmer and they offered as
full and as robust a defensive identity
politics that that the country had ever
seen representation they said had to be
truly a replication of the people in all
of its diversity each local constituency
each occupation each interest had to
represent itself directly farmers
traders and mechanics declared the
Pennsylvania anti-federalists all ought
to have a competent number of their best
informed members in the legislature it
was not enough that the representatives
for the people they had to be of the
people in I think the stockist
articulation of this idea of actual
representation made throughout the whole
if the representatives were to know
intimately the people's feelings
circumstances and interests they had to
be truly of them only ordinary men men
not distinguished by the characteristic
characteristics of aristocratic wealth
education taste could be trusted to
speak for what we're increasingly
referred to as the middling and lower
classes of people so the anti fellows
come to oppose the new national
government for the very reason the
Federalists wanted it because it's very
structure and detachment from the people
would work to exclude any kind of actual
and local interest represent being
represented and and prevent ordinary men
from exercising political power now
Cecilia Kenyon who is a political
theorist that at Smith wrote a very
path-breaking article probably 60 years
ago now men of little faith she would
call them she indict s-- the anti
federal so being men of little faith and
that's true they were men of little
faith they were mistrustful of
government she didn't like that she came
out on the side of the Federalists but
she she had the point was correct they
had no faith in in what the Federalists
were up to because they thought it was
going to be a bunch of rich Gentry who
were going to be making all the
decisions they went on to say in
Federalist and many arguments without
that the awesome they went without
saying they said that the awesome
president and the exalted Senate would
be danger Dangerous lief are removed
from the people but they said even the
so-called Democratic branch of the
government the House of Representatives
which presumably should possess the same
interests and opinions that the people
themselves would possess we're all where
they all assembled even that with its
scant 65 members was a mere shred or rag
of the people's power and hardly a match
for them when article and aristocratic
branches of the government of course
they're thinking in terms of the
traditional mixed government that they
had copied from from an Republican eyes
from from England with Aminata Calista
Craddock in a democratic part if only a
half dozen congressmen widows we're to
be selected to represent a large state
really argued the anti-federalists
really would such persons from the from
the great body of the people the middle
and lower classes be elected to the
House of Representatives the station is
too high and exalted to be filled except
by the first men of the state in point
of fortune and influence in fact they
claimed no ordinary folk will be
represented in the House of
Representatives which was supposed to be
the Democratic branch of the government
except the rich and the wealthy the anti
fellows thought that oh is that all that
that Americans had learned from the
revolution about the the need to
maintain the closest possible connection
between constituents and Representatives
seem to be threatened by the new Federal
Constitution now the Federalists were
not surprised by this argument these
arguments they expected it in fact John
Dickinson in the in the convention said
put it this way aristocracy he warned
will be the watchword the Shibboleth
among its adversaries and precisely
because the anti-federalists says
hamilton observed in the new york
ratifying convention did talk so often
of an aristocracy they didn't use a term
elite but that's what they meant by
aristocracy the Federalists were
compelled in the ratification debates to
minimize and obscure the aristocratic or
elitist nature of what the system they
had had created the an open defense of
the Orthodox doctrine of virtual
representation with all that implied of
an organic and hierarchical conception
of society ruled by a natural elite
smacked too much of an aristocracy or
elitism and they tried to stay away from
it
Hamilton in particular was very much
concerning the ratification debates to
deny that there was any such thing as an
aristocracy but then of course he made
the exact opposite mistake in Federalist
number 35 if you familiar with it it's a
defense of virtual representation that
any Englishman would would support he
tries to to defend he start he's
attacking
the identity politics that's being
thrown up by the anti-federalists he
says the idea and I'm quoting him here
the idea of an actual representation of
all classes of the people by persons of
each class he wrote with more honesty
than than political sense is altogether
visionary that was a term he often used
about things he didn't like that they
were visionaries electing artisans and
tradesmen to the legislature was
impractical and unnecessary he says
mechanics and manufacturers will always
be inclined with you except shion's to
give their votes to merchants in
preference to persons of their own
profession or trades they know that the
merchant is their natural patron and
friend and that they are aware that
however great the confidence they may
justly feel in their own good sense
their interest to be more effectively
promoted by the merchants than by
themselves how I don't think they read
each other's stuff I don't think Madison
want to let them get this go through
this 35 because it's really very very
damaging to the Federalist cause not
only were the artisans and tradesmen
caught up in their occupation said for
Hamilton but they lacked those acquired
endowments without which in a
deliberative assembly the greatest
natural abilities are the most part
useless you went on to argue the same
thing was true of farmers they could
come in the great planners to look after
their interests but then he really what
he really wanted to do in that paper
it's a fantastically interesting paper
was justified representation by lawyers
as far as the learning professionals he
uses that term Luna professions but he
wasn't really thinking about physicians
and clergymen he's thinking about
lawyers the only other profession and
here Hamilton I think meant just lawyers
like himself
they were the ideal representatives they
truly formed no distinct interest in the
society and according to this situation
in talents will have the confidence of
most people in the society they will
feel a neutrality to the rival ships
between the different branches of
Industry and remote and of course these
are all the quotes from the Federalist
thirty-five and were most likely to
prove an impartial arbiter between them
they were the most capable of promoting
aid in a disinterested manner whatever
interests will be conducive to the
general interests of the society
wasn't it better he asked to have as a
representative a man whose situation
leads to extensive inquiry and
information than someone whose
observations does not travel beyond the
circle of his neighbors and
acquaintances such a farsighted
cosmopolitan representative would know
the dispositions and inclinations of his
fellow citizens and will be capable of
creating strong cords of sympathy
between himself and his constituents I
mean that's a stark the whole papers
that the stock defence of virtual
representation now this is not the line
that most Federalists wanted to take
because it's a very dangerous line
because it played right into the
anti-federalists arguments they would
never buy into it the other federalist
much too based on a hierarchical notion
they were trying to hide that instead
Madison James Wilson and most of the
other Federals sought to find some other
arguments to justify and explain their
new system of government faced with
charges that they were trying to foist
an aristocratic system on America
the Federalists quickly realized that
they were better off rooting their
promotion of the new constitution in the
realities of American political
practices none of this echoing of patron
client relationship or the kind of thing
that Hamilton had in in the Federalist
thirty-five they had to show the country
that they were as popular minded as the
anti-federalists
they needed to convince people that they
believed in actual representation as
much as the anti-federalists and they
would do so by drawing out the
implications of actual representation
and throwing these implications in the
faces of the their opponents they had to
convince the country and the anti fellow
said the Constitution was strictly
Republican strictly popular and if they
were going to do that they had to find
as Madison put it a Republican remedy
for these Republican ills that had had
emerged over the previous decade
so they said something to this effect
you want representation we'll give you a
representation and they claimed that
every
thing in the country and the government
was a representative of the people the
federal representatives all elected
officials they said our representatives
the federal representatives will
represent the people they will be the
people and it is not probable that they
will abuse themselves why should we fear
so much great a dangerous for my
representatives in the federal
government then from those we have in
our state governments all parts of all
our governments including the president
the governors the Senators were equally
the agents of the people all branches of
all governments in America were formed
on the same principle preserving
throughout the representative
responsible character these are
extraordinary arguments in other words
all parts of all governments in America
were representatives there's no
difference between the federal
government and the various state
governments these are radical really
momentous arguments they suggested that
both the state and federal governments
and indeed all branches of all
governments were all equally
representatives of the people they were
this argument was made possible by
develops that had taken place over the
previous decade in debates over politics
by contending that all elected officials
at both state and federal levels were
equally agents of the people these
Federalists unleashed ideas that had all
about representations are all kinds of
unanticipated consequences now to
understand what they had done we have to
go back to nineteen to 1776 and the
making of the federal the revolutionary
state constitutions I think you get a
clear idea of what what's new now in
1787 now in 1776 the Constitution makers
had this had assumed that the people
were exclusively represented in the
several houses of Representatives and
each state had a House of
Representatives and that's what they
meant the sentence would not
representative bodies they were a kind
of Republican Republican eyes version of
the mixed Constitution that the English
had the sentence will like the House of
Lords not heretic
Harry but they were to be made up of the
wisest the best people in the society
they're smaller than the houses of
representatives which is the really
representative body and the Senate's had
no constituents they and the governors
were of course timon optical
representing the monarchical element in
this mixed government the idea of which
goes back to Aristotle which is what
made the English Constitution such a
celebrated thing in the 18th century
that it embodied these three simple
forms of government but it soon became
impossible to talk about this in these
terms
almost immediately by the late well I'll
give you the example you take the
example of Pennsylvania which had no
governor and no upper house no Senate
reformers mostly people who later became
federalist one in the Senate they
thought it would curb some of the
excesses that were going on in the in
the unicameral legislature of
Pennsylvania so they wanted an upper
house and they argued for it through the
late 70s for a first Senate like the
other states had well the opponents of
the the defenders of the unicameral
legislature of the Pennsylvania
Constitution argue well what do we want
to send it for that you're trying to
force the House of Lords on us and on
our stock receipt and we don't want that
or we don't want the House of Lords well
the proponents of the Senate couldn't
say well we want a House of Lords we
want an aristocratic body to counteract
the Democratic body they couldn't say
that it became impossible to talk in
those terms so I said no no we don't we
don't want to send it because we want a
double representation of the people a
double representation of the people
think about the implications of that now
if the people could be represented twice
why couldn't it be represented three
times four times then of course I mean
it's that's exactly what happened as
people began thinking that's all agents
out there as in some way representatives
of the people and and the Senate's were
beginning beginning to be thought of as
as as equal representations of the
people now it took Supreme Court 200
years to catch up with this you know
Baker versus Carr and that
proportion to say representation
decisions in the 1960s suddenly made all
these state Senate's had they had to
become much more proportionally
representative and they hadn't been in
in the past but the the the original
sentence were not intended to be
representative bodies now this idea of
representations picked up by the
Federalists in 1787 and used effectively
to justify the Constitution all
government in a republic whatever its
nature of function was something of a
delegation by the people and therefore
all parts of the Republican system now
seemed representative essentially
indistinguishable in their character it
was surprising said John Dickinson that
some critics had declared that the
Constitution was not sufficiently
representative of the people even though
the whole people of the United States
are to be trevally represented in it in
three different modes of representation
now the House the Senate and the
president are all representatives not
only was the Senate representative of
the people is as representative of the
people as a lower house but even as
Alexander Hamilton declared in the New
York ratifying convention the President
of the United States will be himself the
representative of the whole people
now if election was the criterion of
representation then it followed that all
elected officials including senators and
governors were representatives of the
people this actually made the term House
of Representatives anachronistic and it
became I think in time although we don't
think about it much today a kind of
awkward reminder of how he had once
thought of popular representation as the
English had actually as just confined to
the lower house of our legislatures what
you have here is the separation of of
government from society and a kind of
detachment you have all of these agents
out there now and the people remain
below them so to speak delegating them
you have
and once you get away from the English
mixed government you abandon the notion
of estates in the society the society
being embodied in the government which
is what made the English Constitution so
remarkable and of course gave Parliament
King and Parliament is sovereignty it
was election by the people not the
number of chambers in the legislature
declared John Stephens of New Jersey
that made our governments the most
democratic that ever existed anywhere
this is when you begin to have people
saying well we don't have a mixed system
we have a democratic system every the
people are everywhere in the system and
with us concluded Wilson James Wilson
the power of magistrates
call him whatever name you please are
the grants of the people now Wilson I
think was I think he's the equal of
Madison actually in his ingenious 'no
sysm agitation he certainly comes up
with the most imaginative answers to
some of the some of the anti-federalists
criticism he said he goes on to say it
was not just the upper houses that were
now agents or representative of the
people governors and judges he says
we're to the americans of 1776 he went
on had not clearly understood the nature
of their executives and judiciary's
although the authority of their
governors and judges became in 1776 as
much the child of the people as that of
the legislators the people could not
forget their traditional colonial
aversion to the executive and judiciary
and their fondness for their
legislatures which under the British
monarchy had been the guardians of their
rights and the anchor of their political
hopes even at this time Wilson noted
with annoyance people can scarcely
divest themselves of these these pre
possessions the legislators often was
still called the people's
representatives implying though probably
not avowed upon reflection that the
executive and judicial powers were not
so strongly or closely connected with
the people but it is high time said
Wilson that we should chastise our
prejudices the different parts of the
government were functionally but not
substantively or socially different the
executive and
paulus are now drawn from the same
source and now animated by the same
principles and are now directed to the
same ends with the legislative authority
those who execute and they and those who
adjudicate the laws are as much the
servants and therefore as much the
Friends of the people as those who make
them truly extraordinary argument now
conceiving of the judges is just another
kind of agent a servant of the people
helped to make possible of course the
emergence of what we come to we came to
call judicial review and Hamilton
suggested as much in in his Federalist
number 78 which some of you are familiar
with he wanted to justify judges setting
aside acts of the legislature now it's
not easy to justify that we've come to
accept it pretty pretty freely but at
the time it the idea of appointed
officials setting aside an act of a
popular legislature seemed very
undemocratic but he what he what he said
in that what he says in that paper who
those legislators think they are who do
they think they are do they think
they're the people they're not the
people the judges are as much the agents
of the people as the legislators now
that's an extraordinary argument but
that's the gist of what he says and
that's where his justification is for
judicial review a judicial review he
said did not by any means suppose a
superiority of the judicial to the
legislative power
it only supposes that the power of the
people is superior to both and that
where the will of the legislature
expressed in its statute stands in
opposition to that of the people which
of course is declared in its the
Constitution's the judges ought to
regulate their decisions by the
fundamental law and not pay attention to
the statutes in other words and of
course this is made sensible by the
development of the constitutional
conventions which had there's another
element that had developed particularly
by by the Massachusetts Constitution of
1787 other-- representation of the
people and stands aside and superior to
the ordinary legislature
and that's of course gives the
Constitution a kind of superiority to
the to the statutes which are only
passed by the legislators so these ideas
are all flying around and representation
is spreading everywhere sovereignty lies
with the people and they never give it
up entirely now of course this argument
had consequences that Hamilton scarcely
foresaw he said once judges began to be
called agents of the people as
representative of the people as the as
the legislators some soon concluded well
if they're representatives of the people
maybe we should elect them and of course
the first reference that I found of that
argument is 1805 there may be others
that I just haven't come across yet but
of course it doesn't get implemented
right away it's only in the Jacksonian
era that people begin electing judges
particularly in the new western states
and of course as today we have 39 states
that elect their judges if it weren't so
hard to to amend the Constitution we
would probably have the federal judges
elected as well Hamilton certainly never
anticipated that argument to be picked
up but once he threw that out people
could pick it up and run with it now
ultimately this new idea of
representation create a very different
conception of government from the
English one that the Americans have had
thrown off because of the English with
their virtual idea of representation
conceived of Parliament as embodying the
whole society all these states of the
realm are in Parliament there's nothing
outside that gives you that gives
sovereignty to Parliament Parliament
possessed full sovereignty that what
they meant by sovereignty in the 18th
century and I suppose we still mean it
the final supreme indivisible lawmaking
authority in the state and by contrast
the Americans with their acute idea of
actual representation indeed their acute
mistrust of the representational process
necessarily concluded that sovereignty
if it had to exist had to remain with
people themselves it could not be
delegated to any of their agents or even
all their agents put together the
American people unlike the English were
never eclipsed by the process of of of
representation or election when the
English elected the House of Commons
that's it they're out of business until
the next election and the whole society
is in that Parliament and therefore that
Parliament can do anything I mean
theoretically and that's the notion of
sovereignty Americans never reached that
point sovereignty and they use that
argument comes up again the issue of
sovereignty because the answer I fellas
raise it the Federalists have to answer
it
they have to locate sovereignty in the
people it's Wilson who does that he's
brilliant polemicist so when they refer
to the sovereignty of the people they
didn't mean just that the government was
derived from the people everybody
believed that even the English all
English Whigs believe that but instead
they meant that the final supreme and
indivisible lawmaking authority of the
society remained with the people
themselves not with their
representatives or with any of their
agents in America thinking all public
officials became delegated and
mistrusted agents of the people they
were temporarily holding only bits and
people pieces of the people's power
which was sort of speak out on temporary
loan but to keep the basic power
yourselves that that's the conception it
comes out of these debates and actually
this creates a kind of disembodied
detached government which is a I think
an innovation in politics certainly in
Anglo American politics the English
continued to think up until very
recently that the whole society is in
Parliament we never reach that point the
society always it remains outside and we
delegate bits and pieces of the people's
power to these temporary
agents
and the government if sovereignty
therefore is never divided in any
institution or even all the institutions
of all put together now we're thinking
of the people in this extraordinary way
Americans were able to conceive of
federalism you could delegate some
powers to the federal government some to
the state governments some to you
Constitutional Convention summit to
every every institution had its bits and
pieces of powers and by creating two
legislatures operating with with
different powers operating over the same
territory the Congress and the separate
legislature of state legislatures
Americans offered the matter the world a
new way of organizing government only by
conceding of sovereignty remaining with
the people can Americans make sense of
their new constitutional achievements
which I think are quite extraordinary
the Constitutional Convention the idea
of ratification of constitutions now the
English didn't need conventions a
constitutional convention or popular
ratification to change their
constitution because the whole society
was already in Parliament and King and
the people did not exist politically or
constitutionally outside of it except at
the moment of election now this is
changing in England and has been
changing over the last half-century once
you begin once the English had a proper
head a referendum on an important issue
like joining the EU then you've opened
up a gap if you think about it between
the Parliament and the people and that
is a kind of gap because we have a big
gap but they have opened a little gap
that is is it could be worrisome before
for English constitutionalists and they
also have begun using a judicial review
but not by by by appealing to treaties
that the English Parliament have signed
having to do with human rights and and
with the EU and some judges of
beginnings you
but this is a beginning of something
that is really quite small compared to
what Americans do now this wasn't just a
convenient political fiction as my good
friend Edie Morgan has argued the
American people unlike the English
retained an actual lawmaking Authority
it's not a fiction this idea of
sovereignty of the people and this has
been this has been used throughout our
history and particularly in the
Progressive Era when you begin to get
all these reforms of ballot initiatives
referendums and and processes of recall
introduced by progressive reformers at
the beginning of the 20th century these
are all the extensions of the idea of
actual representation carried to an
extreme these expressions of direct
democracy of course are based on a
mistrust of the representational system
and they are extreme expressions of
actual representation now we in the East
aren't much plagued by this direct
democracy to the extent that people in
the West are but if one is from
California or Oregon or Colorado it is a
really major problem of how you handle
these examples of direct democracy so
far most Americans seem content with a
representational process of go although
the reputation as you know of the
Congress is about as low as it's ever
been
and with that reputation and with the
reputation of most state legislators the
cry for more direct democracy is likely
to grow in the coming years I mean I
would say by the middle of of this
century with everybody all wired up
technically speaking it would be
possible for all of us to vote on the
national budget and I wouldn't be
surprised if some converses some day
suggest that and so on April 15th
we'll all sit around our computers and
vote on the national budget won't that
be fun
that's where representation has taken us
thank you
thank you very much I'd be happy to take
questions comments they had an age
restriction which we used to have of 21
they had also talked about the early
state constitutions they had some props
some of them had property qualifications
which were not great but certainly the
idea behind these qualifications of
various sorts was based on Independence
they wanted people who are independent
they felt that women of course were not
independent they were dependent on their
husbands or their fathers and young men
are dependent on their fathers and their
families therefore they should be
excluded from the suffrage that would
been the rationale independence was
crucial you don't want someone voting
because they're not a free person and of
course slaves or other servants could
not vote the there was no upper limit
nobody was excluded because they were
too old but the point that should be
made is is that this is the largest
suffrage of any of any state in the
world at the time so whatever the
restrictions might be by modern
standards you have to take that into
account as I say in England didn't come
close to having the kind of suffrage
that we had
the Electoral College came about because
they could not agree on how the
president should be elected now they did
suggest in fact it was Wilson has
suggested direct election by the people
that was dismissed not because they miss
trucks with the people they just didn't
know how one thing once they get past
Washington how would the people know
whom to vote for they didn't conceive of
political parties with with platforms
and candidates nominated they didn't
conceive of modern media so they said
well once we get past George Washington
how would the people in Massachusetts
know who's who's notable in South
Carolina to vote for so they went back
and forth they said well let's have the
Congress vote for the president they
said well they don't make the president
dependent on the Congress all right well
then I have the president have a
seven-year term not eligible for
re-election that way once he's elected
he'll be free of the Congress he won't
have to count out to them that's how the
debate went seven years was too long
they said for a man that wield that kind
of power so they went back and forth and
they finally said let's create an
alternative Congress with one function
only and that's the electric what we
call the elating call it the electoral
college it's going to be an alternative
Congress it had the same members of same
numbers of people that existed in the
other Congress it's going to be made up
of equally talented people from diverse
localities and these notables and that's
what who they expected would be elected
to thee to this electoral college would
would know whom to vote for who are the
prominent people who are the people were
talented and that's how it we came about
now it was really once you got past
Washington really worked the way it was
intended to work and it had to be
reformed once you had parties emerging
with the twelfth amendments
that's a real problem I think that's
what lately was smart enough to realize
that and therefore the English system of
ritual representation makes sense of
majority rule otherwise if you come to
believe that election is the criterion
of representation and the sole criterion
of representation then you don't feel
represented by the person that that that
lost if you voted for the ban of the man
or the person who lost then are you
represented and you've raised that
question virtual representation handles
that problem because they say well
there's a mutuality of interest that
exists even if you didn't vote for him
you he's looking after your interest he
or she is looking after interest today
that is the justification for majority
rule otherwise it's a real problem I
just know there's no logical reason why
you should believe in majority rule and
of course it's being contested all over
the Arab Spring is all about this
minorities don't feel safe and they're
protesting Sunnis in in Iraq don't feel
safe under shear rule and they're
responding by bombing blowing up their
opponents it's a really tricky issue you
have to have enough confidence enough
mutuality of interest I suppose to
believe that even if you lost your guy
lost that the 101 is still going to look
after your the interest of your
constituency
now the English in the at least in
theoretical terms Burkean terms you
shouldn't be looking after your
constituency only should be looking
after the whole country's interest but
as you know the 400 we have 435
representatives and
they're 435 different interests and as
many speakers have said it's like
herding cats to get them to look after a
general interest and of course that's
being brought home to us with the
especially with the Republican majority
in the house how to hurt those cats
together is the speaker is having a hard
time doing that
but there is a you raise a very
fundamental question the political
theory
waitis majority rule I mean why would we
accept the majority except it's
practical otherwise the alternative is
fighting but there isn't any other
rationale for it I suppose yeah they
don't well it's hard to know I think it
emerges they read what each other saying
and they begin to to see I think they
immediately knew walking out of that
convention Dickinson had made it
explicit look you're going to get our
stock receipt thrown in your faces be
prepared and so they go to these
conventions ratifying conventions
knowing what the principal arguments are
going to be and so they're they are
prepared in that sense but they do grow
upon one another I should say about
Hamilton and he had and yet got the
notion he hadn't realized that that a
requirement requirement for disingenuous
'no sin in popular politics him yet got
that message it's something that of
course we're well aware of today very
few of our politicians are not
disingenuous they just have to be all
those gaffes that you hear about you
see usually is truthful statements that
they've made about reality that the
American public won't accept and so
Hamilton just hadn't got quite that he
did a better job in the ratifying
debates he was very shrewd and he gave
Melanchthon Smith or she put it the
other way around Mike the Smith actually
uneducated gave Hamilton and Livingstone
a real run for their for their money now
now I forgotten you know you remind me
canna be a point which was all concerted
I think to give you a good example they
were really be fuddled by the
anti-federalists argument that this is
going to lead to a consolidation and
it's going to lead to a consolidation
because of the Supremacy Clause and they
invoked the old idea of sovereignty
which had been the sticking point in the
Imperial crisis if there has to be in
every state 101 final supreme lawmaking
Authority will it go the other throne
says there's no doubt it's going to end
up in the federal government and our
states are going to be drained from all
power and they'll end up measuring the
height of fence posts and laying out
roads and that's what Lu all innocuous
stuff and they they kept hammering that
home about sovereignty which was the
very issue of which the Empire broke
because they Colin this couldn't you
wouldn't accept parliamentary
sovereignty and yet the the the British
kept saying there's no dividing of
sovereignty its indivisible so either
accept if you accept one iota of
Parliament's probably get accept at all
that's the way it works and of course
she says if you don't accept one iota
then you have to be independent well
they thought that was such an awesome
thing that the cost would never say that
but they did in 74 they say we're thus
independent were tied to the to the to
the Empire only through the king and
from 74 to 76 that's the way they all
legally minded so they keep that very
strict and that's why the Declaration of
Independence if you read through it it
says nothing about Parliament says you
have George the third done this because
they didn't have to they had already
gotten rid of Parliament because they'd
been forced to get rid of part of it so
they they only have the tide of the king
and they never meant mentioned the
parliamentary statute
which of course are the things that
bothered them the Stamp Act the Townsend
duties and so on and they say you George
the third have done this this and this
and then they say The Closer they come
and say you George say when others have
conspired others are the Parliament now
the anti feathers show the same argument
in the faces of the Federalists why are
they gonna do they keep saying oh no
we're gonna divide sovereignty some
powers are gonna be with the federal
government some with the state
governments and the an offense is no we
can't divide sovereignty it's all gonna
end up being in the federal government
and finally it's James Wilson brilliant
speech she Gibson out of doors first in
Philadelphia and then in the
Pennsylvania ratifying convention who
latches on and says we're not gonna
divide so we accept the notion of
sovereignty we're not gonna find it
divided only we're gonna relocate it
we're gonna put it in the people and of
course the federal yes tie fellas don't
know what to do with that that's a very
brilliant argument and and they're gonna
dole out little bits and pieces it's
Wilson who understands the system better
than than any one of the Federalists and
the other Sooners they read this speech
or hear about it they pick it up and run
with it
and Madison at first doesn't quite
follow this he doesn't he's a little
confused about how we're gonna handle
this but he they all pick it up right
away
and sovereignty remains with the people
and that becomes the solution to their
problem so that it's a it's not I mean
they must have talked to one another at
various times when they were together
but it when they read about what others
had said in previous state debates they
Pauline mayor's book I think shows this
they begin picking up with other
arguments and they begin there's no
concerted but it is based on on reading
each other stuff and finding what are
the best arguments we can use and it's a
as I say it's our laboratory of of how
ideas change under popular pressure
I mean Quinton Skinner's notion of
intellectual history is justified and
revealed by these debates as well as any
place I've ever seen because everything
so concentrated
within 18 months or so you have these
extraordinary changes and new
understanding of politics that emerge
out of these intellectual contests they
they of course their conception of
Commerce was not at all what we've now
come to think of Commerce and they
certainly would not have anticipated the
present situation not that that makes
the the I mean judicial determinations
have have enlarged the commercial
commerce power to the point where the
government can do almost there anything
now whether they can do what the the
Obama's medical bill proposes is up for
will see but that commerce power has
expanded beyond anything they could have
imagined but judicial even even Marshall
had some imagined abuses of the commerce
power but it certainly was not in the
minds of the framers when they were
drawing this up they didn't think
through that what's how there's going to
be thought of you know twenty years if
they couldn't in Tifton couldn't
anticipate when he talked about judges
being agents of the people if he
couldn't anticipate elected judges then
you see that people don't always
anticipate how their ideas are gonna be
picked up and used against them or in
contrary ways and now what was the other
you had another o term limits
yeah the state's actually did have term
limits on some of their representatives
term limits for judges the federalist
Congress
creates the judiciary and of course if
conical three creates a Supreme Court
and there's no term limits there and so
they actually gave a greater power of to
our judges than even the English judges
now since the act of settlement the
beginning of the 18th century English
judges could not be removed by the king
for for anything except misbehavior they
then other words they weren't at the
will of the king but and this is a lot
of people forget this the Parliament the
House of Commons and the House of Lords
could by majority vote call for the King
to remove a judge and that was really
written into the Massachusetts State
Constitution by John Adams so what the
federal judges achieved was it was a
greater longevity more independence than
any judges in the english-speaking world
at that time and they the federal judges
have you know they have no age limits
nothing every state in the Union has
some kind of limits except my own
Rhode Island is according to a Sheila ma
my state of Rhode Island the only one
that whose judicial tenure is exactly
the same as the federal judges which is
lifetime appointment no qualifications
every other judge in the States has some
kind of qualification either it's age or
election or some kind of limit so they
have the one of the great Federalist
achievements not only creating the
Constitution but then their subsequent
Federalist Party was the creation of the
judicial system and they certainly
because it was not it was immune to
popular pressure they they they reveled
in their creation of the judiciary and
Marshall made the most of it of course
in his in his long tenure yes sir
Wow
I mean you could give the conventional
you know without a sense of history is
another mode of understanding it's not
just information about the past if it's
another sense it's it's gives you a
richer sense of reality and without it
you're kind of two-dimensional
this gives you a fourth dimension if you
will to the world you live in and I
can't imagine anyone not having it it's
akin to to memory but it's not just
memory for an individual it's a society
without a history
it's a society that has no idea where
it's going because you wouldn't know
where you've been you won't know what
you're about so I don't think you know
there's no easy answer to this it's just
that I can't imagine a world that is not
interested in history and and and you
have to be interested in the future in
order to be interested in history PDG
antara would have a book something of a
man and child of man where so she
doesn't have our usual atom dag leash
detectives she imagines a world where
and I think they made a movie of it
which haven't seen but nobody's been
born after the age of 25 I mean the
oldest person the youngest person in the
in this whole world is 25 there hasn't
been another birth since and it's set in
England very history minded society and
what happens to history when there's no
future
and it's a because your hero is a
historian and and if you don't believe
in the future then you don't care about
the past and the past is just sort of
falling away so it seems to me that kids
of all people should be introduced
they're interested in the future but
they've got to have history in order to
to make their way in the future but
there are a lot of answers that want to
get to that question
could you restate that that's the way a
political theorist would pose the
question a historian would not I mean
the Federalists won but as Pauline Mayer
shows in a really wonderful book on
ratification there was a lot of
conniving they had every the whole elite
was on their side you know Franklin and
Washington they had 90% of the
newspapers on their side and it still
was a close-run thing and in fact if
they had been a kind of modern
referendum or modern poll taking there's
no doubt the majority of the people in
the country were opposed to this
constitution this
I mean think of it they just fought a
war to remove far removed political
power and now they've created this this
government the strong federal government
and we know it's strong because it's the
same government essentially we have
today ten years after after they had
repudiated one it's just it was
unanticipated unexpected and it was so
novel that it's amazing it got through
I think that's points to the seriousness
of the crisis and that's why I'm not
satisfied with explanations and say well
you know the articles weren't working so
well and they needed a taxing power and
so of course that that's true but that
gave the that was everyone accepted that
all the anti-federalists accepted the
idea that they had to be some additional
powers given to the articles but what
they didn't expect was what they got
they didn't expect this Virginia plan
and they certainly didn't and of course
even that was modified and lessened to
to to the actual Constitution I think
what as a historian and I talked to
Pauline about this because you know when
I first knew Pauline years ago she was
such an avid Federalist and she she
wrote a critique of my book saying
and she more or less it read like a
federalist paper she was so on the side
of the Federalists and so I said to her
well how did you come out after the
writing these books she's I'm much more
sympathetic to the anti-federal like
William Finley who became a kind of hero
for me because well it has to do with a
lot of I suppose your attitude some of
these Federalists could be like James
Wilson could be such an arrogant ass I
mean they'll give you one anecdote that
just illustrates this and Pauline uses
it and I've used it
Finlay has no education but he's arguing
in the ratifying debates and he makes
the statement well the swedes lost power
once they got rid of Jew you know jury
trials
well Wilson's on his feet says Chile
trust the Swedes never had jury trials
Thomas McKean who's Chief Justice of the
state Supreme Court he laughs at
McKinley says but what's a jerk like you
saying things like that there was no and
Finley says look I read it somewhere I'm
gonna find I'll find it what he comes in
two days later and he says I've got my
saw he has two sources actually but one
of them is black stone black stone the
Bible for lawyers
McKeen had enough decency to remain
quiet
Wilson has to get up and say well he
says you know I there there you know I I
know there are people who know so much
that they can't remember everything and
he says and I know more I know more
about history and the law than you'll
ever know and I've been that's the kind
of and so you have to feel chisa that
Finley and of course one thing that does
come out of these debates is that if you
want to relate it to our own time a lot
of these anti foes because they're very
naive about things and they have they
concoct this notion that the District of
Columbia is going to be a some horror
show with all the dancing girls and
whining and so on but you know there's
some very strong resemblance to the tea
party people if you read these anti
federalists and so I think what it does
and I think this is
what history doesn't generally give you
what kind of it takes you off of a
rollercoaster of emotions it gives you a
kind of sympathy for everybody
everyone's a victim and you certainly do
have some sympathy for the anti fellows
because they actually win they lose the
battle but they win the fight over the
next half century at least because
Jefferson writes the power with their
support it's anti federal support that
really makes Jefferson you know by by
the 1808 and in Pennsylvania Simon
Snyder's elected governor he's got no
education at all
he's accused of being a clodhoppers and
he says that's right I'm a Claude hopper
in a society of clodhoppers and he makes
that his campaign slogan in wins and
then Daniel Tompkins in New York he's a
wealthy Columbia lawyer from New York
City so what does he campaign he wants
to be governor campaigns us a farmer's
boy already the anti fellows have won
that rhetorically in every way the anti
intellectualism the anti elitism of
American life is their right from the
beginning in the north in particular and
that only changes in the post-civil war
period and we still have a lot of it
today as you know I mean candidates have
to be plebeian they can't reveal
themselves this disingenuous nasaw our
politics and that's democracy there's no
getting away if you if you try to be
honest you just get killed at the polls
so it's an indictment I suppose of
democracy but what is the alternative
so the applicants are interesting from a
lot of points of view because they do
reveal the future at least the immediate
future because the Federalists really I
left as you know they really go out of
business by yeah as a party by by 1820
they don't put a candidate up so I think
that that debate is revealing of a lot
of the issues that still with us elitism
they didn't use that term early they
used aristocracy but that's what they
meant and people who are acting proud
and acting superior people go to college
our snobs I mean that kind of
the statement it's it's repulsive in a
sense and yet if you realize back then
they were saying the same things it
helps get you some sense of balance and
some perspective on on your own time
because you realize we'd been there
before and we survived that we survived
the Civil War we'll get through this
this time too